we're on problem 106 106 the present
ratio of students to teachers at a
certain school is 30 to 1 so the ratio
of students to teachers is equal to 30
to 1 if the student enrollment were to
increase by 50 students and the number
of teachers were increased by 5 the
ratio of students to teachers would then
be 25 to 1 so if we increase the
students by what do they say by 50
students and increase the teachers by 5
so teachers plus 5 the new ratio is
going to be 25 to 125 to 1 what is the
present number of teachers so let's just
we have to let's just simplify these a
little bit we could cross multiply well
we could just write s over T is he 30
over 1 is just 30 is equal to 30 or s is
equal to 30 T and let's substitute that
into this equation because we're gonna
have to solve for the present number of
teachers which is just T excuse me so
let's substitute this here so we get 30
T plus 50 over t plus 5 is equal to 25
over 1 that's just 25 and then let's see
what we could do let's multiply both
sides of this equation by T plus 5 and
you get 30 T plus 50 is equal to 25 T
plus what's 25 times 5 125 125
I could probably well I won't worry
about that let's subtract 25 T from both
sides you get 5t plus 50 is equal to 125
subtract 50 from both sides you get 5 t
is equal to 75 and then T is equal to
let's see 5 15 right it's 15 T is equal
to 15 15 times 5 is 50 plus 25 right 75
te is 15 so the answer is
next question don't around a space I'll
just do it right here problem 107 107
what is the smallest integer n for which
25 25 to the N is greater than 5 to the
12
whenever you see some type of an
equation or an inequality where there
where the variables are in the exponent
and you're comparing numbers of
different bases your first thing that
should register in your brain is how can
I get these to be in the same base and
it should be pretty obvious here because
25 is the same thing as 5 squared so
let's rewrite it that way this statement
is equivalent to saying 5 squared 5
squared to the N is greater than 5 to
the 12th and 5 squared to the end that
same thing as 5 to the 2n is greater
than 5 to the 12th and this right here
is going to be true this is going to be
true when 2n is greater than 12 right
when the exponent up here is greater
than the exponent up here that's when
it's going to be true we divide both
sides by 2 and you get n is greater than
6 and that's so what is the smallest
integer n for which 25 to the N is
greater than 5 to the 12th so n has to
be greater than 6 we can't pick choice a
which is 6 because if we pick 6 then we
would have 5 to the 12th here right and
then it would be an equality but there's
this is greater than so the smallest
integer n now has to be greater than 6
so n has to be 7 so that's choice B
don't get tricked there when you get 6
is your answer you might want to be you
might want to pick a but n has to be
greater than 6 so it's essentially the
smallest integer greater than 6 is 7
problem 108 if x and y are different
prime numbers each greater than 2 which
of the following must be true each
greater than true - they're both prime
numbers so statement number 1 x + y x +
y cannot equal 90 cannot equal
ninety-one let me think about that if x
and y are different prime numbers each
greater than two which of the following
must be true
X plus y cannot equal ninety-one let me
think about that a little bit that means
that I can't have two prime numbers that
equal that when I add them together
equal ninety-one well let's think about
it for something they're greater than
two right they're greater than two
another prime so what do we know about
all prime number is greater than two
well we know that they're both odd right
although all prime numbers are odd as
long as 2 is the only even prime number
so both of these have to be odd so if
I'm if I add an odd plus an odd what do
I get
well one thing one way to think about
this might be second nature to you at
this point but an odd number can be
written in the form two times some
integer plus one right it's some even
integer some even number plus one so I
could write the first odd number like
that maybe I'll say this is X right and
this doesn't I'm just saying that X is
odd I'm not saying that X is prime but
if you're larger than two and you're
prime you're going to be odd otherwise
you're divisible by two and let's say Y
is equal to I know two times some other
integer plus one so if you add two odd
numbers together you get you get two
times k plus M all right two times k
plus M plus two which is an even number
when you add two odd numbers you get an
even number right so the fact that so if
you add two prime numbers greater than 2
you're essentially adding two odd
numbers greater than 2 so they have to
be equal to an even number so they can't
be equal to 91 so statement 1 must be
true statement two
let's think about it statement two tells
us X minus y is even
so once again X&Y are definitely going
to be odd numbers when you add them you
get an an even number what happens when
you subtract them if I were to subtract
Y from X what would I get here
if I were subtracted I would get two
times K minus M two times K minus M and
then the one minus one but this K minus
M is going to be is going to still be an
integer right these are two integers so
this is still going to be an integer and
they're different they're different
prime numbers so K and M are going to be
different so this isn't going to be
equal to zero so the difference has got
to be an even integer an even integer
now it might they might it might be a
negative even integer right because we
don't know that X is necessarily larger
than Y but we know that it has to be an
even integer even integer so statement
two is also correct
now statement three statement three X
divided by Y is not an integer well we
know that X is prime right we know that
X is prime which means it only has two
factors 1 and itself we know that X
isn't 2 we know that Y is another prime
number now if if this statement right
here if X divided by Y if that were an
integer then that means that Y divides
evenly into X which would mean that Y is
a factor of X which would mean that X
has a factor other than 1 in itself
which would mean that X is not prime but
they tell us that X is a prime number
and Y isn't just the number 1 right X is
they're both prime numbers and they are
each greater than 2 so Y is definitely
not 1 so in order for this in order for
this to be an integer X would not have
in order for this to be an integer X
could not be prime since X is prime and
Y is some number greater than 2 we know
that this is not an integer so all three
of these statements have to be true and
that statement e no excuse me
that statement e problem answer
a problem 109 let me do a different
color
109 all of the following have the same
value except okay so we're just gonna
try to do the math real fast here
one plus two plus three plus four plus
five
all of that over three oh it's this one
plus two is three 3 plus 3 is 6 6 plus 4
is 10 10 plus 5 is 15 divided by 3 this
is equal to 5 be 1/3 times 1 plus 1 plus
1 plus 1 plus 1
well that's one-third times this is 5 so
this is equal to 5/3 so after we see the
next answer we should know where we're
going
so the next answer we have 1/3 plus
itself five times right 1/3 plus 1/3
plus 1/3 plus 1/3 plus 1/3 well that's
five 1/3 so that's also equal to 5/3 so
we we should immediately we should
immediately be able to recognize that
this is different than the other two and
assuming that there's only one answer
right they say all the following have
the same value except I think we've done
enough math because we know that B and C
are the same value so an a is already
different so a is probably going to be
our choice and if we kept going D and E
are going to have the same value just
eyeballing it it does look like that's
the case right yeah it definitely looks
like that's the case because if you if
you look at the other two problems yeah
you just you still get 5/3 and II look
confusing but the fact that a is already
different than B and C tells you that a
is a is the answer and I'll see you in
the next video